SAMRAT SAHA: Hello, everybody.
I'm Samrat Saha.
I am a customer engineering
manager for Google Cloud,
and I'm based out of Wisconsin--
Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
Thank you for taking the
time to join me today
to understand our
perspective on how
to deliver a flawless UX for
Black Friday to Cyber Monday.
So on our journey
today, we will-- we're
going to cover a few things.
For instance, we're
going to go over,
what is Black
Friday/Cyber Monday?
What does success mean?
What is UX/CX?
How do you prepare for it?
How you execute on it?
And a wrap-up.
And we're going to go over
quite a few concepts today,
and the goal is to give
an idea as to how complex
an undertaking can be,
and how partnerships
can help you solve for a
business critical time period.
So we'll start off with
design for failure.
All things fail.
No matter how strong you
make it, it is going to fail.
It's how you recover that
makes all the difference.
And this is something that
people find odd coming
from an organization that's
known for reliable services,
but that's precisely sort of
the mind shift or the paradigm
shift that you need
to get used to.
Things fail.
And how you recover define
how successful you become.
So just to put
things in context,
Black Friday to
Cyber Monday-- it's
one of my favorite holidays.
I love Thanksgiving.
For retailers, it's a really
important time period.
For instance, in
2019, Black Friday
saw sales that was over $7
billion in digital sales.
It is up 14% from 2018.
And in 2019, Cyber Monday
had greater than $9 billion
in sales.
That was a 19% jump
from the previous year.
So to put things in
perspective, that's
a substantial amount of sales
that's happening over a very
compressed time frame.
You're literally going from
Thanksgiving to the Monday
after, and you see that much
sales come through time period.
So BFCM-- you know, Black
Friday to Cyber Monday--
execution impact--
when it goes well,
obviously your sales go up.
Revenue goes up.
It's great for business.
What happens if
it goes sideways?
What happens, let's say, if
you have an outage for now?
What is the impact on the brand?
What is the impact on the
customer relationship?
What does a 1% impact mean?
These are really important
business questions
that need to be answered, and
this is where cloud can help.
UX and CX-- user experience,
customer experience--
what is it?
Well, a lot of people
now have mobile phones.
And a lot of people are exposed
to the latest and greatest
when it comes to how
applications work,
how websites work.
That's the user experience.
So for instance, if you're
shopping for something,
and you decide to go and add
three items to your shopping
cart, was that a
smooth experience?
Did the brand make
you jump through hoops
to do that action?
How smooth was the
overall transaction?
A good user experience
enables your users
to achieve the tasks that
they want to achieve.
And customer experience is
sort of the overall umbrella
around it.
It's not just the app.
It's how you communicate
with your customer.
It is how you can
get help if needed.
So that's the overall sort
of relationship, if you will.
UX is very sort of specific.
And invariably,
having a great UX
can make the difference between
making a sale versus not
making a sale.
So for instance, what
does a one second delay
mean to your website?
A 1% delay can mean around a
7% reduction in conversions.
It can mean a poorer user
experience for your users,
and that could also mean
a loss in business, a move
to a competitor.
So UX and CX are pretty
critical in terms
of maintaining the
relationship and making
sure your users actually
enjoy using your products.
And after all, it is
all about the user.
So UX/CX during Black
Friday to Cyber Monday
the stakes go much higher.
So for instance, if you're
delivering a great user
experience when it's not
Black Friday to Cyber Monday,
that's great.
But can you give a similar
experience when there's
much higher load on the system?
So for instance, let's say that
a person can go in and buy,
let's say, a pair of shoes.
And that entire thing can be
done with minimal disruption,
and the user loves it.
Now, during Black
Friday to Cyber Monday,
let's say there are
thousands of users
trying to do the same
thing at the same time.
Can you deliver
the same experience
that made your customer love
your brand during a high stakes
period?
So that becomes
really important.
Stakes go up.
The revenue potential
is so much higher,
but so is the business impact.
If things go down, how
do you recover from that?
What happens when,
let's say, that you
have users in the east coast and
you have users in the midwest?
Can you give similar
user experiences
to both sets of users?
Because it wouldn't
be right-- it
wouldn't be a consistent
experience with your brand
if somebody, say, in Milwaukee
has a three times higher load
time than somebody,
say, in New York City.
So these are considerations
that become really important,
but again, it amplifies so
much more during Black Friday
to Cyber Monday.
To help you understand
this, to help you figure out
what is important versus
what is not important,
I would encourage you to think
in terms of critical user
journeys.
So what is important
to your user?
What is important
to your business?
So for instance, a user--
it might be really important
to buy, say, crayons
so they can ship it to
their niece in Florida.
Now that can be super important.
That user journey
is really important.
Now, for your
business, it might mean
that you want to have a
feedback survey filled out,
because you get information.
You can better your service.
But to a user, that may
not be as important.
But there are zones
of intersection
between what's
important to your user
and what's important
to your business.
And when you figure out
where it intersects,
it can help guide
you in terms of where
do you need to
put more resources
to harden those systems.
So for instance,
checkout is super
important to your
business and your user,
because a user wants to go
buy stuff, have it shipped,
and complete it with
minimal disruption.
For a business, it is
extremely important, too,
because that's a straight
line to the money.
So you can figure out what
the intersection points are
to help guide you design your
systems, harden your systems,
and provide the best user
experience for a business
critical time period.
So why is it so hard?
I kind of alluded
to this previously.
During Black Friday
to Cyber Monday,
you could see up to 3x to
4x, three times or four times
the traffic than
you would normally.
And there is no--
it may not be a steady pattern.
It could be very spiky traffic.
So you might see a whole bunch
of users hit your systems
within the first hour of
your sale starting up,
or it could be something
like you have several spikes
because you have promotions
going out every other hour.
So the traffic is very spikey,
and it is substantially larger
than what you'd normally
find outside of Black Friday
to cyber Monday.
So with that in mind, how
do you account for that?
Traditionally, what
you would do is
you would have a
set of compromises.
You would say, you know what?
Black Friday to Cyber
Monday is critical to me.
In order to meet
that demand, I'm
going to over provision my
resources throughout the year.
So now you're paying
for redundancy
for the rest of the year.
Or you compromise and
say, you know what?
I'm willing to take the hit.
I'm going to sort of
under provision knowing
that it has a slightly negative
impact on my customers,
but that's a compromise.
And that's why having your
resources in the cloud,
having cloud native sort of
mentality towards developing
your solutions can really help.
Are your resources elastic?
Can they grow and
shrink with the usage?
Are they redundant
across different regions?
What happens when, say,
a region goes down?
These are the kind
of things that you
have to bring to the
table when you're
trying to address a very
distributed user base who
have high expectations
on a user experience,
because that's
kind of what you've
grown to build with your users.
You've built a
relationship that you
want to protect and nurture.
And with all that comes in stuff
like you have a distributed
system.
How does a database
handle asset transactions?
How do you guarantee
that consistency?
These are the sort of things
that start cropping up,
which are not normally seen
in traditional monolithic
application, not normally seen
in traditional deployments.
So these are things that
make it much harder,
and it usually takes a
completely different approach
to be successful in the cloud.
But the payoffs are there.
The payoff, as well.
The payoff is, again, a
great user experience.
I cannot stress this enough.
What the goal should be
is provide the best user
experience so that a user
can enjoy working the brand
and building the
relationship up with you.
So what does it look
like kind of internally?
And this is fairly sort
of standard in terms
of how people approach--
how teams approach
approaching peak.
You have capacity plans.
You've got to figure out how
much capacity you'll need.
You have load testing.
You have tabletop exercisers.
So this is stuff like you
sit down and figure out, OK,
our database has gone down.
What do you do then?
Let's say you decide you're
going to simulate a network
outage to the east coast.
What do you do then?
How do you feel?
Then obviously you have
Black Friday to Cyber Monday,
and sometimes it's
code-- depending
the organization
you are, sometimes
you institute a code freeze.
Sometimes you don't.
It depends on your approach
to how you develop products.
Black Friday to Cyber Monday--
and then tapering
towards December
you start scaling down.
So you understand your capacity.
You scale up.
You test, deliver,
and scale down.
So all this is a very,
very compressed timeline
of very sort of--
a lot of activities
going on just to deliver
on that short time frame.
So breaking down, first of
all, definition of success.
What does success mean?
This is a business
critical objective.
What does it mean for a business
in order to be successful?
Once you have that, you
can start figuring out,
what do you need to
do to deliver on that?
Then you have core
activities-- load testing.
Do you test to three
times to four times
the amount of load
that you normally get?
Tabletop exercises, which
I just went through,
do you assimilate sort of
different failure scenarios?
And you figure out, what are
the lines of communication?
How do you respond to outages?
Disaster recovery
testing-- this is something
that Google is famous for.
This is where you
figure out things--
again, things are going down.
How do you recover?
How quickly do you recover?
Where do you recover to?
Failover-- let's say
that you have regions--
compute regions
in east and west.
Sake of argument, let's
say east goes down.
How do you failover so that
your users on the east coast
are not significantly impacted?
There is a degradation
of service.
That's for sure.
The latency went up, but how do
you make sure that they still
can use your service?
And that's key.
Rollback strategies.
What happens when you decide
to push an update out?
Can you roll back smoothly?
Let's say that the update
caused a bug that was not caught
until it was in production.
Sometimes these
things do happen.
Can you actually roll
back and with confidence?
Communication-- how do
you communicate failures?
How do you communicate outages?
What is that internal
business process?
And most importantly,
who decides?
Who's the decision maker?
So let's say that
we decide that we're
going to failover
from central to west
for the sake of argument.
Who's going to pull that button?
Who's gonna push
that button, rather?
Who makes that final decision?
Are those chains
of communication--
have they been
clearly demarcated?
And are teams empowered
to make those business
critical decisions?
So again, fairly complex,
but for really good reasons.
Now, do you have
the architecture
to deliver at peak?
Is your application--
or your application--
are they monoliths?
Was it distributed
services, micro services?
What kind of cloud design
patterns are you using?
Are these multi region systems?
Are these distributed systems?
High availability
disaster recovery?
4-9's, 5-9's reliability.
You've got to figure out
what your error budget is.
You've got to figure
out how much effort
are you willing to put in to get
a certain kind of reliability.
Because nothing is going
to be 100% reliable.
You've got to figure
out your trade off.
Implication of
your systems layer.
The implication of
your compute layer.
The implication of scaling.
So again, the architecture that
can help you deliver for peak
becomes really,
really important.
So this is a sample
architecture of, let's say,
an e-commerce-ish application.
And there's certain
things that are
pretty common in this
kind of architecture,
but the key is you
start with the user.
You have users distributed
across the nation or globally,
and the fundamental part is
you route a user, if you will,
to the resources
that is required
to complete their user journey
that's closest to be used.
In this case, what
you're seeing is
you have region one on the left.
You have region
two on the right.
Connecting those two is a
cloud load balancer on top.
So think of it as a request
coming in from the user.
Hitting the load
balance, which decides,
should I send the user's
request to the east,
or should I send the
user request to the west?
Region one or region two.
Within those regions, you
have compute resources.
In this case, you have GKE.
You have-- essentially that's
more for Microsoft's kind
of approach.
Then you have a
persistence layer.
You have Cloud C could have
NCache or Datastore, whatever
is important to your business.
Underlying all that, you
have an analytics layer.
So BigQuery.
And the architecture is a
distributed architecture.
It's a highly
available architecture.
If a region goes down,
and you resume services,
in this architecture you can.
Is this repeatable?
What if you decide to
stand up a third region?
This architecture
is modular enough
that you can repeat what was
successful in both regions
and stand up another region.
This allows you to also
test pushing out updates.
So again, it's a very
distributed architecture,
and it gives you the
flexibility to scale up.
It gives you the safety to
withstand regional outages.
It also gives you the
template, if you will,
to expand out as
your business grows.
Now, this is a fairly--
these are some of
the services that you
would have in a traditional
sort of e-commerce application.
As you can see, you have a
whole bunch of digital services.
You have search,
taxonomy, a whole bunch
of services that are required
for a user to be successful.
And you have other services
that are non-digital,
like shopping, delivering,
stuff like that.
But again, what I'm trying
to impress on you is,
to deliver a great
e-commerce application,
there are a whole
bunch of services
that need to be built
out, and there's
a lot of cloud
native design patters
that you've got to
implement to be successful,
especially because, again, are
your services elastic enough?
Is your infrastructure elastic
enough, resilient enough
to handle high loads, and to
allow for disaster recovery
to happen if things go
badly, and also scaled down
once you've executed on peak?
So this is a topic
all by itself.
I did want to mention it--
site reliability engineering.
This is very user impact driven.
This is more about for an
infrastructure for somebody
who maintains say
hardware, alright,
so let's say for an
example, or somebody who's
developing an application.
Things of interest
might be, what
is the CPU percentage, of
utilization percentage?
Now those are interesting
things and are important
pieces of information that
help you solve for problems.
But what is the
impact on the user?
If you don't start approaching
it from user impact--
for instance, let's
say that you want
a user to be able to browse for
the products on your website,
and you want the search results
to be returned within, say,
one second.
Now, if that is impacted, now
that's a user level impact,
and that can help guide the
business better in terms
of solving for a better system
that is providing such results.
Now the underlying cause might
be, let's say, CPU utilization.
But if you're not guided
by the impact on users,
it becomes very hard to figure
out what is important for users
and what is important
for business.
I would encourage you to go into
SRE and get a lot of resources
on-- at Google Cloud to help
you understand, where does SRE
fit in?
And how do you develop and
deliver reliable systems
at velocity so that your
developers, your product teams
can make cool stuff,
but they can also
deliver stuff reliably, and
maintain reliability, as well.
Common threads of success--
so in my time at Google,
I've seen some teams
be very successful in
delivering a great, great Black
Friday to Cyber Monday.
And some of the things that
I've noticed that my teams as
well have noticed
that helps people
be successful-- there are clear
objectives, communication.
Great communication.
People know-- your objectives
are being communicated clearly.
The teams are empowered
to make decisions.
And this trust-- they embrace
cloud native thinking.
Again, it's designed for scale.
The elasticity that is important
to deliver on those experiences
is really important.
And then the power
of partnerships.
Leverage your partners.
They have helped solve some
of these problems for others.
And more importantly,
it is in their interest
to help you be successful.
So it's sort of the
all-embracing approach that is
defined--
that is sort of guided
by overall objectives--
business objectives,
user objectives.
Success on GCP--
as you can see, we
have quite a few
of our customers
who have partners with-- partner
with GCP to be successful.
And hoping that we
can help out you
achieve your business goals.
Thank you.